bis jetzt war alles entspannung die hört
jetzt auf vor allem wenn du die roten
lose zieht die roten sind unverschämte
fragen die grünen sind harmlose fragen
du kannst selber wählen du kannst du
viel wie du möchtest dann können wir
fangen aber sind alles herausforderungen
weil die grünen fragen sind so fragen
die haben der habt ihr die gemacht ja ja
die haben nicht überall kann man gekauft
wie man nicht ärgern kann und was deine
besonders hervorragenden eigenschaften
sind also nach denen fragen wir auch
glaubst du wirklich an zwar sagen wenn
ich ehrlich bin eh ich glaube da nicht
dran man muss dazu sagen dass steht in
deiner bio also in dem promo
geländewagen hätte mal gesagt wird was
besonders diese wahrsagerin die da ist
meine schwester gegangen und sie hat mir
vor kurzem
die aufzeichnung gezeigt was sie gesagt
habe mich und sie hat gesagt genau erst
tanzt ein bisschen aus der reihe
schwarze schaf der familie muss man sich
aber keine sorgen machen da kommt man
ganz groß raus ich glaube eigentlich
nicht haben so war das eben so über
natürlich ist und esoterik
aber manchmal erwische ich mich manchmal
selber so zweifel so denkt so auch dass
das alles sogar was du in maßen ist das
wirklich gut die richtige entscheidung
so klar die wahrsager den hals auch
gesagt was hier wird mal was also mach
dir keine gedanken für mich ist das so
eine art beruhigungstablette diese
wahrsagerin geschichte und die wieder
einmal an die tür gibt sich momente
wurde manchmal denkst das stimmt jedoch
nicht irgendwas ist hier übersinnlich
oder ich sag mal wann war dein größter
erfolg schub denkst da kommt das jetzt
plötzlich ich glaube ich glaube ja auch
ich glaube ja viel ein zufall und glück
und man kann die musik branche
eigentlich ganz gut beschreiben dass die
besteht nämlich zu 90 prozent aus glück
ja das ist talent und harter arbeit
und dann ich erkläre mir das immer so
man freut sich einfach dass man zur
richtigen zeit am richtigen ort ist
manchmal noch pech dann ist kommt man
gerade zu spät so und dann ist kriegt
ist ist ein anderer da aber ich hab' ich
kannte danke sage ich habe schon viel
glück abgekriegt gut sechs wochen
nächste mal eine grünliche mal grüne das
sind so die die ferse auf die baby
fragen ja die bbv
wieso kommst du beim publikum so gut an
ja
weil sich jetzt auch
ja davis
ich glaube weil ich einfach ein bisschen
die grenze geht einfach versucht alles
zu geben und ich nicht als nächste
konzert denke oder an den nächsten song
sondern jeden einzelnen ton so singen
als wäre es mein letzter
und das spüren die leute
hoffentlich gut sehr schön eine rote
jeder sollte manchmal auch konzerte und
denkst du jetzt mache ich anders oder
das würde ich jetzt anders machen oder
acht er macht das gut oder das dilemma
also man kann sich schon ganz schön viel
abgucken bei anderen künstlern auch also
ich habe auch schon viel support
gespielt also für die vorband sachen
gemacht und ich habe versucht von jedem
was mitzunehmen ob das bei simply red
ist für mick hucknall oder bei ich mich
was abzugucken da muss man sich auch
inspirieren lassen weil man ihn zuletzt
aber nicht nur vom front mal ins gesicht
schlagen das ist nicht von allen
manchmal höre ich auch was mir niemand
was spielerisch okay das muss irgendwann
handy singe das war das schöne war also
bist du eine niete in bwl absolut ich
bin die absolute flasche was alles mit
zahlen anbelangt man glaubt es kaum
deswegen hast du dich mag warum das
studium in obwohl auch wohl nicht
entschieden obwohl ich bwl studiert
haben her dass das ding war ich hatte in
der dritten klasse abgewählt und dann
mit ach und krach irgendwie so immer
durchs abitur gerutscht wusste nicht was
ich tun sollte fangen also an bwl zu
studieren wäre aber keiner gesagt dass
das ganz ganz viel mathematik
und dann musste ich von vorn anfangen
und allerdings echt los mit
hochrechnungen prozent regelung sowie
wie ein kleines kind wieder anfangen und
war dann stolz wie bolle als ich dann
doch irgendwie jede prüfung so gerade
eben gekriegt hat
aber
dazu gibt es ja heute auch immer
taschenrechner
grün
du brauchst den frauen nur in die augen
zu schauen und schon sind sie hin oder
blauer mit leuchtend einspringen ja das
habe ich mal gewesen ist
er hat geschrieben dass ich hier
geschrieben ja
weiß man nicht was sind deine augen
ich tue ich es ist mir unangenehm sein
lichtschwert roth
sechsmal ist ja klar das wollen wir
jetzt auch gleich nein musste in einem
song reparieren singst du dass du eine
schraube locker hat welche ist das genau
welche genau das ist weiß man nicht aber
sind nicht nur hier und da sicher noch
ein paar sind absolut richtig
zusammenpassen und gehören das kann
können die leute um mich rum auch mit
sicherheit bestätigen
die lachen schon welten
ich glaube aber wann man muss auch ein
bisschen hin da mal eine klatsche haben
sonst
kommt man auch auf gewisse
gedankengängen nicht und auf vielleicht
auch der auf texte nicht oder auf musik
ich kann da ganz gut mit dem laser haben
wir nicht alle einander klappt ja
nun geht man nicht
woher kommt eine phänomenale
ausstrahlung mein gott ihr seid aber
heute ja das ist ja ein richtig geiler
pudding ja nur komplimente die man
ich war von meiner mutter natürlich ja
ja die hat ja auch meine mutter weiß ich
sehe die schönste frau der erde und wenn
ich irgendwas
tolles von untergehen kann dann
vielleicht der ausstrahlung gut ok habe
ich meine mutter auch noch schön fabian
sutter muttermilch aufgesogen auch so
jetzt noch eine rote und noch nicht
also
in einer jugend war angeln im fluss sein
hobby bist du ein langweiler
ich bin bestimmt auch langweilig ja ja
also wenn angeln langweilig ist ich habe
das eigentlich als langweilig empfunden
sondern und das ist ja noch schlimmer
für mich wichtig da für mich war das
immer wieder es gab ein fluss und ich
glaube ich war der einzige der was zu
essen rhein geworfen hat deshalb war das
nicht langweilig weil die fische alle zu
mir haben ich habe also so lange
angeführt hat bis ein riesiger schwarm
da war und ich also immer was gefangen
habe von daher wurden gegangen weil ich
habe die andere eingehalten hat ein
fisch gehabt und den habe ich dann für
fünf mag damals an unsere nachbarn
verkaufen weil ich selber mag ein tisch
ich freue mich nicht nur angeln
das letzte kompliment
wie so siehst du so blendend aus na ja
meine mutter eine mutter ich sagte es
schon und ich
einfach ganz ganz viel liebe jack
täglich von morgens bis abends werde ich
gut versorgt und gepflegt
das ist das geheimnis dass das geheimnis
meines erfolgs
man ihr seid aber auch echter ich bin
die ganze zeit klar wahrscheinlich
ja vielen dank das war clixoom für heute
gleich spiele ich noch einen song live
auf der gitarre für euch